hi i'm christopher hine and today we're
going to be giving you a few details for
um the disarm so one of the patrons on
here asked me to give a couple details
about my code guys disarm and how it
works i'm going to give you some
close-up video on it and kind of explain
a little more detail how my code guy
should disarm works i'm gonna get josh
out here we're gonna go to work josh
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so this video is for paul paul
asked for some more detail on my
disarming technique with kodagaish and
he said he was kind of running into some
trouble let me give you the basic form i
got three different kinds of knives here
to kind of give you three different um
ideas of what's going on so this is a
knife that i use i actually i bought one
of these years ago and then i made a
whole bunch more myself because i think
they're really good for training some
aspects of knife stuff so let's get a
close-up here
so um this knife has a really big one
close your hand around it this knife has
a really big pommel and what's nice
about it is when you're just training
this stuff it pretty much will always
give you a grip on this side of the
knife right so it's good to kind of get
guys working initially with it even if
he chokes up quite a bit on that sucker
this way yeah get rid of that pommel see
there's still pommel and like look
that's how does that how comfortable
does that feel in your hand right so
almost everyone's gonna hold it right
about here which gives this guy a lot of
room to work with here and we'll talk
about when that disappears here in a
second okay so when i'm in code guy's
position i'm over here and i have my
basic grip lock going on by placing my
hand over his hand now understand this
came from
suppression and then i caught this hand
like this and now i've closed his hand
around it now i have to have that to
keep him from switching right and once
my hand's there even if he does open his
hand and do a switch that's fantastic we
call this the mike douglas because one
of my students mike douglas
used to do that all the time it was
irritating but it's a fantastic
technique so my hand goes right here in
front okay now when i'm going to do the
disarm this hand is going to mimic his
hand as much as i can right so i'm going
to slide it in here just like his hand
is i want him to be the same right so
it's identical to his hand this hand is
going to be opposite his hand like a
exact mirror image of his hand right
just like this so he's there i'm like
this and a mirror image then what i want
to do is get as much of my ring finger
and pinky finger over this uh pommel as
i possibly can so i'm really grabbing
down there okay and then i'm gonna pull
this side and push this side and what's
happening here and i don't know how
close this is but um i'm i'm literally
pulling the knife right out where he's
grabbing it right there so where the
opening of his hand is is where i'm
working so i'm not really worried about
trying to apply a coat of guys we know
it to hurt the wrist but i'm just
worried about turning the hand this way
and this will automatically turn the
wrist to that position
anyways right so i don't have to worry
about that but a lot of times when i
tend to think about just doing the coat
of gosh what happens is i lock his hand
onto the knife better and it's hard for
him to let go and that's not what i want
i want him to give up the knife
so with this knife here i'm going to
grab as much here as i can as much here
as i can i'm pulling on this side and
i'm pushing on this side and you get a
super sweet disarm with that it comes
out really really well okay so that's
with this knife all right let's go to
the kind of knives you guys are using so
paul's group's using these quan nines
which i use here i like them
they have a very very small handle here
right so it's not a lot of handle to get
but still i can get in here on this side
and instead of relying as much on this
part of the pull which feels really
really good i'm going to rely a lot on
this part which is the push so as i get
the hand into the good position i'm
really going to drive that knife back
towards him with this now on a single
edge knife this is perfectly fine
because this whole thing's flat and if i
needed a little more force i could even
come out here right and so it depends on
how risky you want to be right but i
could come out all the way here if i
want and there's japanese techniques
that show pinching the blade like this
so that way nothing could cut me but i
get a longer lever and the longer level
i have the better it's going to be of
course if the knife was like this long
it'd be fantastic because i get a full
hand here and a full hand here and i can
pull that sucker free but i can't right
so so i'm limited by this so i get as
much as i possibly can in here even if i
need to slide my fingers in between his
hand like that and i've done this many
times or you just shoot those fingers
inside there and i can get more purchase
on this and then i make a lot of this
because the handle's so short about
driving this side back towards him so
i'm really working that okay then a
knife that i made
so i made this knife and i made it with
a really tiny handle so josh got tiny
hands but still you can see how there's
almost nothing back here and there's no
pommel protrusions right so there's no
nothing for me to get a hold of here so
now i've really got to work another way
with the technique so i get in here now
look i can't get my fingers in at all
now i've still pinched them in there as
much as i can possibly get but i'm not
really going to rely too much on these
to pull the knife free what i'm going to
rely i'm doing is anchoring my hand to
his hand and then i'm going to drive
this into him as hard as i possibly can
so i'm here and i'm using this knife and
i drive that into him right now look i
had no purchase on this side so i had
the same problem that i think you guys
are running into which is you can't pull
it out this way right now if i had a
knife like this probably with just this
hand i could i could pull it out of his
hand right but with this knife i really
don't have any purchase here right so
all i'm doing is locking into it and
then i'm driving the blade from here
right at him now on a single sided knife
that's super super easy because there's
there's nothing back here but even on a
knife that that doesn't have you know
the whole handles really really short
his hand's not going to be getting cut
here right because he's going to have
his hand where it's not getting cut so
even on a double-edged knife with a
short handle so i can put my hand next
to his and those are right now to each
other that's maybe a quarter inch off of
his hand there at that part so i can
really drive into that to get it to
force free so i push and i pull and i'm
really pushing this towards him okay now
if i cannot get it and this is one thing
that paul's group did is they worked
this idea of rolling the hand now that
hurts like hell right so josh definitely
had a big reaction the problem with it
is it hurts while his hand is locked
onto the knife and then when i let up so
he could open his hand to let go of the
knife he locks back down on it because
now it doesn't hurt right so then i got
to crank into it again so you have a
real hard time making a clean disarm
with that so a lot of times if i can't
get it out i want to give them enough
trouble that they lock their arm out so
let's say i'm working this and he's
resisting me he's going to start
straightening his arm more and more and
more because this gives him more
strength at the wrist now that's great
for me because that leads into chondron
right here where i can go into that
elbow now from this he's probably going
to do one of two things either he's
going to jerk his arm down because he
doesn't want to get rokued and i drive
in here boom and i get that disarm or
as i do that he won't give me that so i
just worked the rokyo now so i just
conrad it into the rokyo right so the
idea here is to drive as much in this
way as possible right you see i'm
hitting that same problem you guys are
hitting right that's a sticky point
every time but when i hit that sticky
point i drive this side right back in
towards him and that's what i'm working
so
does the shorter if the handle gets
shorter it's going to be harder as the
guy's grip gets stronger it's going to
be harder but what you really want to do
is work the blade side as much as you
possibly can if you keep your hand
tucked tight to his it's going to make
it easier to slide up in there so i'm
christopher hines this is joshua teehee
and maya solano mcdaniel is right there
behind that camera thank you very much
for watching
[Music]
foreign